great
okay so next we have uh lillian ratliff
uh
who is local at least for me uh she's
from university of washington so
very far from where i am right now and
she's going to tell us about
gradient descent ascent uh converging to
minimax equilibrium
billion you can take it away thanks yeah
i'm going to talk about
uh yeah brilliant descent ascent in
zero sum games and min max problems and
this is a
joint work with my student tanner fees
here at uw
so just to kind of give some context
a recent sort of trend is leveraging
game theoretic abstractions for machine
learning and
optimization problems so probably um
one you guys are somewhat familiar with
is using
game theoretic abstractions for finding
robust machine learning solutions
and so uh one of the fundamental
abstractions you see is actually either
a
min max optimization problem or a
zero-sum game for many applications
um and despite the efforts to analyze
the
partial bandit feedback cases uh
provable convergence in the full
information case uh still remains
elusive in particular for first order
methods
so the goal here is really to take a
step back
and look at first order methods with
full information
and then once we have some provable
guarantees there
uh transition to the partial information
or bandit setting um in order to show
that
uh the obtainable epsilon stationary
points are actually game theoretically
meaningful
okay so the setting um is going to be
continuous uh games continuous zero-sum
games with sufficiently smooth cost
functions
uh and um the min max optimization
problem
is such that uh the minimizing player
is minimizing f with respect to x1 and
the maximizing player
is maximizing with respect to x2
and as mentioned we're going to talk
about gradient descent ascent
it's a fairly natural learning rule
where
each player is either descending its
cost or ascending its
its utility function maybe one slight
difference from the usual way this is
formulated is that we allow the
players to have different learning rates
which leads to
what is known as tau gda so tau captures
the time scale separation between the
players
and it's actually this specific
parameter that allows us to get provable
convergence guarantees
and here without loss of generality i'm
letting tau be equal to
uh the learning rate of the second
player over the learning rate of the
first player
and just some additional motivation the
existing algorithms that give guaranteed
convergence to game throughout
game theoretically meaningful points um
at present as far as i'm aware
require second order information so this
would be
fairly prohibitive in terms of the
online setting where would require
a lot of sampling to be able to estimate
second order information
um but from an empirical point of view
uh we've actually seen that first order
methods work well
with time scale separation and this has
been demonstrated for example
in gans where you see uh the effects of
time scale separation through unrolling
for example of the the discriminator
that's sort of a proxy for this
uh time scale separation that i'm
describing here
okay so what's known um so we know that
in the case when there is no time scale
separation
you can have spurious stable points that
don't have any game theoretic meaning
however all of the strict local nash are
contained inside the
locally asymptotically stable points for
the
update um but you can also come up with
examples and i'll show one in a few
slides
such that the strict local min max are
not contained inside the
stable uh attractors for the the update
on the other end of the spectrum as taos
scales to
infinity in this limiting case it was
recently shown by
chi jin and his collaborators that the
local stable critical points in fact
coincide with the
uh strict uh local minmax points
i have a question in this infinity case
why isn't it like
shouldn't we just assume that there is
one player that optimized to optimality
and the other one is doing the gradient
steps
uh that is basically what's happening um
in the limiting case yes
so then it's kind of
obvious or it's it's intuitive at least
it's intuitive i would say i don't think
uh so there's uh cheese approach which
um he uses um
um i guess it's like the moral envelope
or something like this to be able to
prove it and then there's an alternative
approach which uses actually a pde
um in order to like solutions to a pde
to be able to prove that in the infinity
case this works out
um and that's what i'm citing here is
this book from kokatovic
it's a control theory result so i i
don't think it's
yeah i think it's intuitive but it's not
obvious uh just to write down the proof
of sense um
okay so yeah so what we'll do is uh you
know so the issue with the infinity case
is
um that it doesn't lead to an
implementable
gradient descent algorithm so what we
want to do
is uh figure out like sort of what's in
this in between space
and basically our result shows that you
can actually construct this
a finite tau such that the stable points
coincide with these strict local min max
okay so just a little bit more setup we
need some equilibrium notions
uh and so again this is uh zero sum game
defined um on
well here we'll take it for simplicity
to be euclidean spaces but that's
in because we're considering the
unconstrained setting
we don't have results for the constrain
setting and the cost function is
sufficiently smooth
uh and so uh we have two notions of
equilibria the first is a local nash
um and basically i've defined this here
in terms of the best response maps
on some uh open neighborhoods u1 and u2
um and the reason for that is that it's
instead of the usual inequality
definitions
um it's motivates the the refinement
that i'll define in just a second uh
and the other notion is a local min max
or local stackelberg
equilibrium where the modification is
really that the first player is taking
into consideration that the second
player is playing a best response
and so looking at these definitions what
we do is we
define a differential notion of
equilibrium concept
using the sufficient conditions for
optimality for each of these
different local notions of nash and
stackelberg respectively
and so differential nash is basically
what you see in the blue and the yellow
box so
um each player uh
is at a point where their individual
gradient is zero
and where their individual hessian is
positive and negative definite
respectively the differential
stackelberg notion
basically also contains this condition
that the second player is at a local max
the difference is that we can take this
local max
condition and use the implicit mapping
theorem to get the existence
of a neighborhood and an implicit map
such that we can kind of replace
this constraint that is an optimization
problem
with the implicit map so it maps you
know x1
to x2 and using that we can then write
down
optimality conditions in terms of the
total derivative
for the first player and that defines
our stackelberg differential stackover
notion
so i think some comments are due for
like what are the connections with the
the broader class so on the left we have
these
inclusions pictured i think the more
important point is what's on the right
so it's fairly straightforward to show
that differential stackleberger in fact
generic amongst local stackelberg
equilibrium what that means is that
in the space of gains defined by
sufficiently smooth cost functions
uh all local stackelberg equilibria are
differential stackelberg equilibria
except on a measure zero set
within the the space of uh games
and the same can be said for different
the relationship between differential
nash and local nash
in addition uh both of these equilibrium
concepts are robust to smooth
perturbations in the player cost
okay so now what i'm going to do is
first talk about
stability of the tau gda
dynamical system using tools from
dynamical systems theory and then we'll
talk about
convergence rate and i'll tie it back to
the the online learning when you have
partial information or abandoned
feedback
all right so the tool that we use uh to
analyze this
update you can use all kinds of
different methods the tool we use is
uh from dynamical systems theory so we
basically
look at the continuous time limit as the
step size gamma one goes to zero
which defines this continuous time
version of the tau gda
update um and once we have a sense of
how
what the stability of this continuous
time dynamical system looks like as a
function of the parameter tau
then we can go back to the discrete time
system and characterize
the convergence rate in terms of uh
gamma one
the way that we study stability for the
continuous time dynamical system
is looking at the local linearization
around critical points
so critical points are such that this
vector g of the individual gradients
are zero or is zero
and yeah so at critical points we can
take a local linearization of the
dynamical
system and this defines this game
jacobian
j tau which is pictured in the middle
basically it's a block operator matrix
that contains the individual hessians
plus some interaction terms
and so we can say when a critical point
is stable for this dynamical system
by looking at the spectrum of the
negative uh
of this game jacobian so if it's if the
spectrum of the negative of j
tau is an open left half plane then we
say the point is stable
and this is equivalent to saying that
the spectrum of j tau is in the open
right half plane
and i point that out because i'll use
both
uh in the the slides to come so
understanding stability
um with respect to this local
linearization
uh uh then can be uh
used to say something about the
nonlinear system itself using tools like
hartman groveman
okay so this game jacobian is actually
has a lot of structure in it as an
operator and we can connect it back to
our
differential notions of of equilibria
um simply by looking at
the different block components so a
differential nash
besides having the individual gradients
be zero is such that this red and the
blue block are positive definite
and a differential stackleberg you have
the red block be positive then it turns
out the second order condition
the second total derivative uh
differentiating twice through the
the implicit map for the zero zone case
is just the sure complement of this
matrix
so all of our notions of equilibria can
be checked
uh by looking at this uh block block
operator matrix
all right so now to the sort of main
point uh we want to
show whether there is this finite tau
and if it if it does exist then we want
to construct it
such that we get provable convergence to
uh only these
uh strict local min max so
i will motivate the results through two
examples
which basically answer some simple
questions
so the first thing is whether or not um
unstable uh differential stackelberg
equilibria when tau equals 1
becomes stable as you grow tau and the
answer to this is yes you can easily
construct simple
quadratic games where the first player
if you look at its individual hessian is
at a saddle point
so that the overall dynamical system is
unstable
uh but the critical point is uh a
differential stackleberg
so then as we grow tau we see that what
happens is
at this critical point uh a critical
value i should say
so towards not to confuse with critical
point um
uh of tau equals two uh the system
becomes marginally stable and then
uh is stable afterwards and in the right
plot you can see this because
uh the eigenvalues of j tau the real
parts of the eigenvalues of j
tau all become positive after tau equals
two
and so the intuition here is basically
what's happening and this kind of
motivates actually the tau going to an
infinity case or give some intuition for
that as well is that
you can show that what happens is that
as you scale
tau the spectrum of j tau
splits into two pieces one corresponding
to the sure complement of j
and the other corresponding to a linear
scaling of the
second player's hessian
okay so the second question is whether
or not these spurious stable points
remain stable as you scale tau
and it turns out that they actually
become unstable and again a simple
example shows this
so we have a critical point at 0 0
that's not game theoretically meaningful
and then two other
differential nash equilibria and just as
a reminder
differential nash equilibria and the
zero sum setting are also
differential stackelberg or strict local
minmax
and so what ends up happening as you
scale tau again we hit a critical point
which it happens to be 2 again in this
case
such that for all larger values of tau
the trajectories will avoid this
critical point zero zero so you can see
the red and green trajectories
are no longer like the blue and orange
will converge to zero zero
for example in the left plot and then
they diverge away
and go to this other critical point um
for
tau equals 5 and 12 which are the red
and the green
okay so answer these two questions um in
the affirmative and so what's left is to
really
formalize these into a general state two
general statements
uh so the first statement is that if we
have a critical point
um that is essentially hyperbolic so we
need that
um the uh sure complement has
determinant on zero
and the same for the individual hessian
of the second player this is a
generic condition in general um
then uh for this case we can construct a
finite tile star
such that for all larger staff all
larger tau the continuous time dynamical
system
uh converges to a this critical point if
and only if it's a differential
stackable equilibrium
the second thing we can show is that if
the spectrum
for when tau equals one is in the open
left half plane so the point is stable
for one
gta and the second player is at a local
max
then you can argue that x star is in
fact the differential
sackleberg equilibrium so that's enough
to ensure that it's a
differential stack over equilibrium and
we know that
our the tau gda will converge locally
asymptotically for all
tau uh greater than or equal to one so
this second point is important
um just to connect to some of the recent
online learning literature for min max
problems because typically what is
studied or what
the regime that we know uh reasonable
results
is this non-convex strongly concave
setting
and this um second condition is
precisely that that case
so the second player is always at a
strict
maximum okay
so instead of going through uh how we
argue this i thought i would introduce
this uh like really interesting tool
that lets us construct tao
taostar it's known as a guardian map
and basically the idea is that we want
to figure out when this parameterized
class of matrices uh when its spectrum
leaves the open left half plane so you
can do that by constructing a polynomial
in the variable tau
and varying tau and then
see exactly when the
eigenvalues of j tau leave the open left
half plane
and this map this polynomial that you
construct is called
uh a guard map sorry lillian can you
explain like it's probably completely
trivial but why
is it that we have this monotonicity
property is that
there is a tower star where any tower
after that
is going to be good um perhaps it's
easiest to see from
the actual construction there is no soft
argument
that would
uh soft argument or
or like
what what is the intuition in terms of
the gradient descent ascent that you
know there is a
time scale separation which is such that
like it could i could imagine some
cycling properties where you know
between certain boundary of
the time scale something happens and
then you make it bigger something else
happens and
yeah so i guess the intuition is
probably
just from this fact that you can argue
that the sp this thing at the bottom
that the spectrum
you can argue that the spectrum splits
into two pieces asymptotically as tau
grows
and these two conditions are exactly the
conditions for
uh that's the most intuitive
answer i think i can you and sorry sorry
if i'm slowing you down
why is it that we have this split again
uh it's hard it's i don't think there's
a good intuitive answer the way
to see it is that uh basically you have
to define these polynomials
for both the sure complement and this uh
individual hessian yeah which basically
are the characteristic polynomials for
those matrices and then you can define a
pde in terms of those two things
and then find solutions of this this pde
it's really not it's highly not trivial
i think so
nice okay that's one way to prove it she
um
and uh purnith have a slightly different
way to prove it i think
which is also not intuitive okay that
sounds nice
thanks
okay so yeah so let's construct this
guard map
and i it is a pretty messy construction
but i think the
intuition it comes from if you're
familiar with lyapunov theory for
linear systems um so this is the most
intuitive way i could come up with
explaining this so basically we know
that a matrix is stable
if and only if there exists this
positive definite symmetric matrix p
that
um you know essentially solves a
lyapunov equation
so we want this operator a transpose p
plus pa to be negative definite
and if we think about the vectorization
of this operator it turns out it's the
kronecker sum of a transpose with itself
so that means we can take uh this local
linearized
dynamical system uh defined in terms of
negative j
tau um and write down
its corresponding vectorizely openof
operator
and we just want to define a polynomial
in terms of tau so if we take the
determinant of this
basically this will be zero only when
this
operator is
not invertible and this operator is not
going to be invertible when we don't
have a solution to this lyapunov
function and the reason that you know
the sign of the polynomial
um you know goes from being uh one thing
when tau is less than tau star and then
something else uh
flips to the other side when tau is
greater than star has to do with the
the fact that the spectrum of this
chronic or sum
um is exactly uh the pairwise
sums of the eigenvalues of uh
of minus j tau itself so these pieces
together kind of give a sense of why
this is the right
guard map it is not the only guard map
actually there's tons of guard maps you
can construct for
the open left half plane but this is the
one that i think
makes the most sense in terms of you
know typical notions of stability
uh for linear systems so then once we
have this
uh we can use some clever properties of
chronic or sums
uh and chronic products to reduce the
polynomial
into um basically four pieces so we have
tau uh scaled to some power
and then we have two non-zero uh
constant pieces
and then we have an eigenvalue problem
in terms of some matrix b
which i didn't write down because it's
messy and so
we can determine exactly when tau when
nu of tau
becomes 0 by looking at this eigenvalue
problem
so we can find the the largest positive
real root
for the polynomial defined by
determinant tau
i minus b if it exists and otherwise
then tau star will be zero and the way
we get a tight construction on tau mean
there's no smaller tau
for which the system is stable is by uh
reducing the chrono curve sum
to what's called a block chronograph sum
i didn't know anything about these
things until i started
looking at this problem and um yeah it's
kind of messy stuff i think
but it's it's pretty nice because you
can just reduce
uh the uh the matrices by using
something called a duplication matrix
that yeah reduces all of the
redundancies in symmetric matrices
okay so i won't talk much about the
instability result
basically we can write down a
generalization of the question too so it
says that there's this
finite uh tau naught such that any non
game theoretically meaningful critical
point
that was stable becomes unstable and the
idea of how to prove this is to combine
leoponof's theorem
with something that's known as
sylvester's inertia theorem which says
that
any congruent matrices have the same
number of positive negative and zero
eigenvalues and then we can derive a
contradiction from these two facts
the instability result is only
interesting because we can combine it
with the stability result
and a known result about avoidance of
saddles in games
in order to sort of completely
characterize convergence of
tau gda all right
so i'll quickly talk about rates so we
want to go back from continuous time now
to say what we can
what is the right value of gamma to get
asymptotic convergence
and then connect to the online learning
setting
hopefully in the last slide okay so i
won't go through this theorem it's messy
basically we can get an asymptotic
convergence rate in terms of parameters
alpha and beta where alpha and beta
depend on the eigenvalue which maximizes
the spectral radius
of the operator identity minus gamma j
tau and the only reason we need to to
look at that
uh is because j tau is not symmetric
so that occurs in games if you had a
potential game for example or you were
actually optimizing a single cost
function
then you can easily just use like a two
norm expansion
and then the theorem for the rate
becomes much cleaner
and alpha and beta are usually chosen in
terms of the
the singular values of
uh whatever your dynamical system
is defined by so your symmetric matrix
in that case but since we don't have a
symmetric matrix
we get a little bit messier uh result
okay so this is um second to last slide
basically i want to connect back to the
the main problem
which is thinking about how do i do
learning when you don't have information
so the first case would be stochastic
case you have
an unbiased estimator of your gradient
uh
so just basically a noisy gradient in
this case we can combine our
finite tile results with known analysis
for stochastic approximation to get
almost sure local asymptotic convergence
and high probability concentration
bounds so basically what's called a
lock-in probability
the difference is now we only require a
single learning rate schedule
usually in this literature to get
convergence to
a min max point you would need both
players learning at
uh with some learning rate schedule
meaning like some
time varying step sizes that have pretty
restrictive assumptions on them
and so the insight for why this works is
basically that
uh all the critical points
that are internally uh yeah so all
critical point
internally change transitive invariant
sets so i say that because there could
be
other attractors like cycles and stuff
um
of this talgy sgda update are going to
be the stable points of this continuous
time
limiting dynamical system and hence
because we proved those were all
you know differential stack of work for
a certain regime
of values of tau that gives us pretty
strong guarantees in the stochastic case
and so i have we haven't done any work
on the zeroth order case
but uh this is my conjecture that um
recent work that came out this summer
earlier this year
on uh min max problems with zero zeroth
order optimization
we should be able to improve the
convergence rates using
this choice of tau by optimizing over
this
choice of tau and in particular in the
non-convex strongly concave setting
what we get what we should be able to
get is instead of just converging to
epsilon stationary points
we could show that all of those epsilon
stationary points in fact
game theoretically meaningful meaning
they're mid max points
okay so i'll just wrap up so basically
um you know thinking about online
learning with in minmax problems in
particular these unconstrained ones
you know it seemed reasonable to take a
step back
if we wanted to get guaranteed
convergence
to gain theoretically meaningful points
we needed to take a step back
and understand the full information
setting
in order to get provable convergence for
first order methods
which was previously unknown so that's
what we did here um
and in fact we were able to get sort of
a full characterization of the
optimization landscape by combining the
stability instability and saddle
avoidance results
i think uh there's two sort of takeaways
this definitely leads to a partial
explanation for the success of
heuristics
uh that people have been using so people
intuitively understood that you
should be doing this sort of unrolling
or time scale separation
um and that worked well in practice and
so this at least put some theory behind
that
the other thing is that i think this
guard map uh
concept has uh quite a lot of strength
in terms of what it can do for both
analysis
and synthesis of game theoretic
abstractions and machine learning and
optimization
so it actually falls within this class
of uh mathematics called the geometry of
polynomials
and um i think that it's uh
opens up some interesting directions for
yeah synthesizing algorithms that have
good convergence guarantees so as an
example
we can construct a guard map not just
for the open uh
left half plane but for a band around
the the real
axis and empirically we observe that you
get the fastest rate when you have a
small amount of complex
component in your spectrum relative to
the size of the real
uh component of your spectrum and so
um yeah using a guard map of that that
nature you could
optimize various hyper parameters in
order to
ensure that you have fast rates of
convergence
okay so i think i'm about out of time so
i'll finish there
thanks uh do we have a quick
burning question
we can take more questions during the
discussion period but if there is one
quick question now we can also take it
okay i have some questions but i will
keep them to the discussion uh thanks
lilian
thank you eva if you want to try to
share